[Applaudissements]
alors coup de coeur coups de gueule on a
un coup de gueule
2 oui un confrère me tenait un énorme
coup de gueule contre un reportage passé
hier soir zinedine zidane dans
complément d'enquêté
utv pourtant et pourtant j'aime bien le
journaliste poincaré qui s'occupe de
cette émission mais là c'est un scandale
mais d'abord il n'y avait rien de
nouveau c'est que des vieilles histoires
ensuite passer à douze jours c'est les
singulières donner trop important pour
toi film c'est à deux jours à deux jours
d'une finale de ligue des champions où
il entraîne le real madrid
qu'est ce que france 2 via nous mettre
un complément d enquête qui n'a aucun
intérêt
est ce qu'on veut déboulonner notre
idole messenger participerait du centre
ville et à belize à riom est passé chez
les saines habitudes il est tout le
temps en train d'hurler justement après
les documentaires qui parle peu dit il
et là on a agi béni oui oui
à partir du moment mérimée mais on
s'attaque à quelqu'un qu'ils aiment ça y
est ils n'aiment pas et bien justement
c'est ça qui est bien dans son montage
c'est que nous on a ainsi nadine zidane
qui est différent de celui qu'on voit et
effet la musique où nos clients tout à
cannes iv
[Applaudissements]